joining me here on the rich eisen show
in advance of
his movie wander in theaters video on
demand and digital
on this very day none other than aaron
eckhart how are you doing aaron
excellent thank you very much you got it
so uh
based i remember on uh the conversation
that we had last time you were in studio
i'm looking at you right here is that
is that the black of silver and black of
of the uh oakland raiders the the beard
and the and the
and the the voice that's the silver and
black that you're
i peppered my beer in honor of the
raiders
uh no this is old age here very good
yeah and uh i haven't started dying it
yet
um no i'm uh i'm still a raiders fan
that's good can you not be uh so
you know you're you're from northern
california right that's where you're
you're born and bred into raiderdom
through that way
i was born in cupertino in san jose um
at a time where um i'm not sure i
mentioned this on
your show last time but go for it there
was a an
office building there in san jose and
they put up this weird
sign it was an apple
you see what i'm saying i do because you
know so many people with their iphones
when they look down at their phone and
see the time
zone certainly on the left coast it says
cupertino on it yeah cupertino and so
when i was a kid that
first and everybody said it was an apple
a rainbow colored apple i guess
and uh everybody said why would you name
your company apple
and imagine because my dad was in the
computer in the computer business that's
why we lived there
and uh had we put money into that little
machine
i wouldn't be talking to you now that is
for sure
you'd be self-funding all your movies
let's put it that way you'd be doing
that
so you do have a memory of like oh god
like i i noticed that that's an
interesting logo
up there huh yeah i remember that i
remember that place was a ghost town
when i was growing up
and now you know you can't get through
it i mean all the way up to san
francisco and menlo park and
and uh and all that um you know
when i was a kid there's still orchards
there and the raiders you know were
the raiders and the a's and the niners
it was it wasn't big business then that
i remember
you know not like today today is beyond
you know your your imagination in terms
of the business and all that sort of
stuff
uh and now the rents in fact the house
that i
grew up in was just a little
three-bedroom house in a neighborhood
i think my dad bought it for 60 thousand
dollars
and um i heard it just went for two
something
you know and it's not even near these
places
nice well and now here i am now here i
am
um you know where while i'm talking to
you
i have some notes here on my my iphone
my ipad right here i'm talking to you on
a zoom through macbook air i mean
it's amazing what the world is and we're
all now connected
and um you know and things have been
totally changed and that's why i'm
you know when you hear on these football
games about next-gen stats and like this
player got up to 20 miles per hour
on this play and it was an eight percent
chance of this pass not being completed
i'm an old gen stat guy
wins losses you know baseball home runs
runs bad at it i'm an old gen stat guy
you know
does that start affecting the experience
of the game as a fan
you know when you're more interested in
stats i know with fantasy football and
betting and all that
right that's what kind of confused me in
the last few years was
uh you know what's more important wins
and losses
or how fast he ran or how many
completions they have or what's
rush per play you know all that starts
to become more important i think instead
of you know hitting hard
you know playing the game right being
tough
so it's an interesting different
experience today yeah i don't know
aaron eckhart here on the richison show
i don't much of a baseball fan
uh or how into the sport you are
certainly these days but
a huge you know for the world series
this year about
blake snell the tampa bay uh
the tampa ray pitcher being taken out in
the middle of a game with a shutout
going and he's only giving up a couple
hits
because the analytics say it's time for
him to come out based on all the numbers
and the gut and feel issue is gone you
know and
i was one of those people like saying
what happened to gut and feel
you know what i mean like that's what
you're talking about i think
what do you think happened to it good
question
i i i'm one of those i don't know
i'm one of those guys that's just like
hey this picture's on a roll let's go
you know like again
maybe it's because i'm looking at you
with your beard you got a very jack
morris look going
you know like jack morris those days of
going into the 10th inning of a game
seven of a world series are gone
like we'll never see that again aaron
the question is that i
that comes into my head is uh is the
coach more interested in losing or is he
worried about
or is he worried about losing or does he
want to win the game
and uh uh you know because the coach
the coach i'm sure his instincts are
saying leave him in leave him in
right you know hey what's it going to do
to the game what's it going to do to my
player in the future
what's he going to do his mentality and
do i you know
do i want to keep a happy player um on
the other hand
what are his bosses saying you know is
the pressure from
up in the booth and uh in corporate is
that
really in the back of his head is that
who's managing the game
yeah i think what we're kind of hitting
on here just i guess bring it a little
full circle from where you're from the
money ball the oakland days moneyball
the movie moneyball the book moneyball
and
and what it's become and um you know
it's just an interesting aspect but
analytics are
are you know i guess here to stay in
many ways with sports and
but like i said that's why i like the
old gen type thing so who was your guy
growing up aaron who was your raider
stabler right yeah and for this exact
reason
because the snake he would run all over
the field you know look at fran
tarkington
he didn't care you know he wasn't going
to get fired that's why we love brett
favre you know
and coaches that are going to go for it
on fourth down and one you know in
inches
and they're not going to run the numbers
they're just going to go for it and come
which way
come with me i think that in the long
run the fans will appreciate
the not only the coach and the player
but they'll appreciate the team and the
experience more
if you go in with that attitude when you
start playing prevent and all that sort
of stuff
you know it's just no fun for the fans
you know could you imagine if somebody
ever told
stabler you know our numbers say you
should throw it here
you know our numbers say you should just
check down check don't throw it deep you
know
pocket could you you know bradshaw
throwing you know in the fourth quarter
to swan or something like that you know
he's got you know three teeth you know
he's got he's got the one
the one bar takes his helmet off his
hair is everywhere
that's what i love about football you
know today it's a little bit more
buttoned up it's obviously more
corporate
and you can say it's the same thing
about the movie industry you know it's
the difference between
what i call studio films and independent
movies like the one i just made
one i just made is brad shaw with no
teeth in the front and his hair
everywhere
and he's going for it on fourth down
studio films is more like
i don't i won't say what but you know
what i'm talking about yeah
it's a little bit more buttoned up well
i guess it's better
that that if you're going to talk
bradshaw on a version of movies that
that you're not making i guess the
bradshaw smokey and the bandit 2
right but that that actual terry show i
weren't seeing
yeah or or he might have been in
cannonball run i mean i'm trying to
think about terry's
movie-making history right now off the
top line good movies
are you smoking the bad at hooper
good good time for movies and sports i
thought
oh my gosh what's your favorite let's
let's let's touch on this then a little
bit here before we get to wander
and then a little bit more of your
filmography uh what what is your
favorite sports movie
aaron what do you love well uh besides
the one i was in
i was in any given sunday i played nick
crozier
that's right uh you know
i can tell you stories about that movie
i'm all interested please what do you
got
what do you got oh just about
pacino and you know uh as a coach and
i just i i don't want to we just it was
a great time to be with we i mean we had
all
everybody was on the set you know
because we made that movie in miami
we had every we had keyshawn we had jim
brown we had them all and everybody came
and visited you know everybody that was
in miami so you'd show up and
and everybody would be there and um it
was just
it was it was fun seeing al
who i i don't know how much he knew
about football at the time
mm-hmm and uh and being the coach and he
gave that inspirational
uh uh uh um the ancient
inches yeah it was electric and you had
all those pros in there and they were
riveted
yeah like lawrence taylor's listening to
that speech on inches and he's locked in
exactly lawrence and they after out
everybody
spontaneously after that scene got up
and clapped and erupted
in cheers and you had people like
lawrence taylor uh
and that's the best speech i've ever
heard a coach say
and there's there's times where i was up
in the booth in dallas stadium
yeah i mean that was and and from the
car park
it's i don't know how many it's got to
be a mile or something and i was doing
up there and i was on the telex
and i was feeding me place you know and
al doesn't know any place you know he's
like t t
y x four three go left you know like
this
so i'm doing my thing and i gotta i said
i took off my allergy wasn't even there
because we were running three sets at
the same time
oliver was filming somewhere else so i
took off my talents and i
ran all the way down the top of dallas
stadium in the booth
i knocked on al's trailer al opens the
door he's in a kimono robe
he's eating shiny stick up with a with a
with a telex
he's shooting a scene giving you plays
but he's
in real life sitting in a kimono eating
chinese food
yeah hilarious
the whole movie was like that i remember
walking on the set my first time and i
was out there
oh this is a good story um
i was uh first day i i just went to go
visit the set i wasn't even filming that
day and we're on the practice field and
i was out there
running drills with the guys and they
had another practice squad going uh
to the left of them and everybody was
working all the cameras were working
right
so i get up there and oliver sees me
goes he goes aaron get in there
i go wow i'm not even working i'm not
even in costume i didn't have it
he goes get in there this is the big
leagues so i go in there
and i stand next to al and al looks at
me and goes what are you doing here
so so oliver goes eric go over there
to this practice squad so i go over to
the practice squad
and i'm standing and nobody knows who i
am nobody knows who i am
and uh these are big football players
tough dudes
yeah big eyes strong kill you and um
and they're running the play and the
scenes going but before oliver says
cut these guys start to uh
start to get lays off they start to you
know um
they start to you know drop the ball
they're not working
so as a coach on camera in the middle of
a scene as an actor i
start yelling at them you pick up that
ball
i never want to see you ever do that
again you work it through
i you know i get right up in the face of
this
big football player and he has no idea
who i am he looks at me because you ever
talk to me like that again
i'm going to kick your ass like that
i said hey man i'm your coach so then
oliver says
cut right because we're still a scene
right
right off his cut and i go i looked at
the guy to go i'm an actor i'm your
coach in the movie
oh so
it was just like that the whole movie
was just bananas and
jamie and uh you know ll cool j
and it was it was awesome and charlton
heston is the commissioner of the nfl i
mean what a
really what a great casting that is
right
cameron was in it and uh you know
jim brown really uh was interesting
character in that because
you know in the movie he was strong but
outside of the movie you could see that
everybody just gravitated to jim brown
and uh uh all especially all the young
players in this they gravitated he would
hold counsel
uh you know between takes in the setups
people would ask his advice what do you
think about this
and they would be very quiet around jim
all the time
because um there was a reverence you
know
um that that other players uh had for
jim
and i didn't know anything really about
it to be honest with you
right now i sort of learned it as it
went and um
very interesting to see he would give
advice and uh
uh was it was a sage sage
counselor well you it's that way to this
day too
aaron i mean a couple years ago on nfl
network uh we had a show to celebrate
his 80th birthday
and invited all um a host of
hall of fame running backs from um
yesteryear but
you know not from jim's year franco
harris and
um and marshall falk and eric dickerson
and to come in and celebrate with him
and it's the same thing
today it's still the same thing today i
i hosted an nfl 100 all-time team show
last year
emmett smith came in and
honestly it's all bowing down to the
goat
jim brown is uh
the advice that he would give people was
um not always what i thought it would be
you know he was uh a strict
disciplinarian
and he really uh talked about money
and how to behave and uh and
and how to comport yourself and sort of
thing
and uh i think it had an effect for sure
um aaron eckhart here on the rich show
there's some great stories right there
man let's talk about wander
um what uh what do you like about this
film and what uh what people should know
as they're making their decisions to go
see a film
digital on-demand uh and also uh in
theaters today
go for it well you know uh
standing up to power you know when
you're you know you think you're weak
you know
to me this movie's about instincts you
know a guy has an instinct
um especially when he's grieving he's on
pills he's he's isolated himself from
society
but he has this instinct inside of him
that says i need to follow that lead
i need to go i need to go track that
down and in the face of all opposition
from his friends his family from
from the powers that be uh he follows
that lead
and reaps the consequences of it but um
he stands true uh truth to power
and um the interesting thing about this
movie is
i play a father that lost his daughter
and lost his wife in a car accident too
and uh and i don't think everything's as
it uh
has been said by the police um
and so people start calling me a
conspiracy theorist and all this sort of
thing and i've looked up that
started to study that and all that and
i've come to the conclusion that when
somebody calls you a conspiracy theorist
when you know it's true they're trying
to shut you down they're trying to stop
the conversation
they don't want you to ask any more
questions and then you have to because
of that you have to ask
more questions right nobody doesn't want
you to ask questions then you have to
ask more questions
and that's an arthur this character
everybody thought he's nuts and he's got
a nutty uh partner
tommy lee jones who's in a hawaiian
shirt and uh yellow tinted glasses
and uh um and so we go on this journey
and the journey's just weird the movie's
weird
it's a nice little thriller and i think
people will definitely enjoy
uh the journey that this um this sort of
whacked out guy goes on
yeah with katherine winick and heather
graham as well um
tommy lee jones do you um in any moment
in time on the set when you're not
working i know again
um you know i'm assuming if you did
shoot it in the last year that there are
certain protocols but
just pick his brain at all i mean you've
been there done that you've been in this
business a long time
or just go fanboy in a little bit of a
way with tommy lee jones
on fanboy yeah right
uh it's just like with jim brown what
we're talking about you know i'm just at
their feet tell me a story
man was it like the old days when you
were working or
what were you thinking when you just did
that uh um
tell me how you do it uh or i don't say
anything and i just watch it
and that's um usually more instructive
because i say i know the script
obviously i know his part i know my part
right hey okay what's your choice here
what are you going to do what are you
going to do with this
and interestingly enough when you're
looking at an academy award winner
american icon actor is usually the
choice that you didn't pick
it's usually the opposite a guy like
that
you know and other actors i've worked
with they usually
when you want them to go big they go
small and when they you want them to go
small they go big
and you go wow i never would have
thought about it and that's what makes
them great
and um you know tommy lee jones what
what let's just hit that one more time
and then i want to hit
before i let you go uh another film from
your filmography because again tommy lee
jones is a part of wander which is the
name of the town actually from this
from this film and just like so many
other uh um
great movies uh there's a nice double
entendre about the the title
um the fugitive for me is a remote drop
that's it like any what's your remote
drop movie
where you are watching or you're home
you're seeing it you're
you're flipping around where just give
me a couple of them for you
where you just dropped the remote it
doesn't matter where you pick it up
you've got to finish it
and blow off your schedule to finish the
movie
well i'm going to go back i would say a
fugitive definitely that's an
excellent i mean tommy just commanded
that movie right
something like that his choices in that
movie the thing about tommy is that he
doesn't make a lot of movement
like i'm jumping around like a mexican
jumping bean you know
tommy lee jones is straight and he gives
it to you straight he's like edward g
robinson
and he's magnetic and that's the way he
was in the fugitive
and he's still totally commanding um i
think movies that affected me
might drop there have been so many but
apocalypse now for sure
um i remember watching poltergeist you
know just in my
you know rocky for sure i was just
talking to sylvester stallone not too
long ago
about something we were on the phone
together and i said
do you understand the effect that you've
had on people
do you understand what rocky means to
people
like me that saw in the theater three
times in 1976
and that i walked out of there a new man
talking about a guy who's an up and
coming
he's in he's down and out he's got a
he's got a uh
down and out coach you know he's uh got
a uh
i mean everything's against him and he
makes it work he does it through hard
work
and i think something like rocky is um
an illustration of the american dream
well i i for somebody in the position of
what i do for a living
it's kind of a controversial take right
i don't call rocky a sports movie
it's a love story it's a love story
that's a
that that movie is a love story between
rocky
and obviously adrian i've mentioned that
to carl weathers when he's been on the
show he thinks it's also a love story
between apollo creed
and and rocky that movie works on so
many it is a
remarkable film and also in the day and
age
you want to talk about great time for
movies i mean i if i'm not mistaken
that was also at the same time network
came out which is another remote drop
for me and it's a
required film for anybody in the
television business to see network
and see what that movie is you know you
know and i
i rarely pick my my my computer up when
i do the zooms at home but
right there you can see that is um
none other than peter finch as the great
howard beale that i have on the wall of
my office
great picture that's a remote drop i
mean look at that
era you know everything from butch
cassidy to uh
you know i mean all the 70s look at
clint eastwood how many mic drops she's
had
or remote drops um
i you know have i ever been in a romo
drop i think the dark knight probably is
for some people no question
about that and that's what i wanted to
kind of hit with you before
i'll let you go especially since for
those you know we're on a simulcast on
radio
to describe you your your your light the
way it's kind of hitting you
your face is in light and half as in
dark
have been i feel like i've been having
an interview with harvey dent this
entire economy this entire time
right now yeah it has been very um
uh you know and we do have christopher
nolan's coming on the show
next week what was that like working
with him
uh tell him i said hello and thank you
uh yes
you know the the thing that
i that i reflect back on that movie was
chris came from independent movies
and i still do him um you know obviously
he's
blown up i mean he is the director in
hollywood i mean he
is the guy but he runs his movies like
independent movies
they're small he runs it everybody stays
on set
there's not a lot in my experience there
wasn't big catering there's not
you know people don't run back to their
trailers and isolate
um they're expected to be on their set
they're expected to be there
when you need them at work chris um
i don't know if he still does it but
every day he'd wear
a vest a three-piece suit he had a you
know his his watch you know in his
pocket right here
means alfred hitchcock um he is an
auteur
and he has a complete command remember
what time i said to chris
we were in england and we were in one of
the largest hangars in the world there's
two of them right next to each other i
can't remember what they're called but
harry potter films there
and we had three of the largest green
screens in the world working at the same
time
right there i said to chris without
mentioning
green screens i said chris you know we
ought to do an action movie one day
he looked at me strange and he goes what
do you think we're doing
and i kind of looked around at the three
largest green screens in the world
i looked at a a railroad car that's
going to crash into this with a
batmobile and everything i go oh yeah we
kind of are doing one
what was that scene uh like with you and
heath ledger in the hospital
what was that like it was an interesting
uh scene uh they were setting up
uh the crew was setting up all the
c-stands the lights
all that sort of stuff and so i went and
i got in bed
and i must have been in bed an hour or
two before you know and just watched
them and everything and
getting used to because i really didn't
know what i was going to do
and um and then all of a sudden i see
heath come in
from the side there didn't say anything
and he's kind of talking to himself and
flicking his
look in his hands again they're you know
walking around
walking around and setting stuff up and
then he starts walking around the bed
like this not saying anything to me
not really looking at me and i'm looking
at him
he walks around a few times kind of just
like this
and then the time he gets on this side
he flicks his arm out like that to me
and then he walks around and he looks at
me strange this way and then he comes
back over and he did the same hand
movement
i grabbed his hand and we did that for
however long they were setting up
we we just did this dance together and
then before you knew it we were so
connected
that all of a sudden the crew just sort
of
did their thing and they left and we
went into it
and by that time we had done it so many
times without speaking
or he would say something that wasn't
even scripted
and then all of a sudden we just did the
scene
and it was beautiful and then the thing
that i liked most about that was
we were walking out after a hard day's
work it was very emotional
and we were tired and we're walking out
and he put he puts his arm around me and
he goes
that was a good day's work
and for an actor to say that to another
actor especially
where heath was going because i remember
in rehearsal or
somewhere i said to gary oldman one of
the best actors
the world has today gary oldman great
actor
i said heath's doing something special
and gary goes
yes he is so everybody knew it and
i mean i remember talking about chris
talking to chris about that he goes
heath is doing something very special
here and um
we were all privileged to be around him
watching that
aaron this has been a blast man i'd love
to do this as often as you are
up for it and wander is available in
theaters on vod
and digital today uh aaron you're the
man thanks for the time and the great
stories just great
thank you very much it's pleasure you
better that's aaron eckhart back here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here